okay welcome back everyone this is the
last lecture of the class of the whole
series of four five sixty four or five
sixty five as everyone almost done with
homework six any big problems or was it
pretty straightforward okay mostly
straightforward okay good so today is
one of my favorite lectures this is the
eigenfaces lecture so what we're going
to do is we're going to apply the
singular value decomposition to
essentially find the most dominant
features of human faces that we can use
to classify the Treynor computer to
classify different people okay so what
do we know about the singular value
decomposition so far what are its kind
of main uses that we've seen
dimensionality reduction what does that
mean exactly it's certainly true that
you can use it for dimensionality
reduction but what do we mean what
dimension gets reduced to what
okay so if I have a bunch of data
stacked up in a matrix X and let's say
that it's a really really tall skinny
matrix oh I have huge column vectors and
I have a few of them then the dimension
I'm talking about so usually I have an N
by M matrix where n is the number of
pieces of information I collect about a
single measurement or a single
observation and the dimensionality
reduction is reducing the size of n so
instead of having to keep track of n
numbers like let's say I take a 1
megapixel picture of a face instead of
keeping track of those million numbers
maybe there are five really really
special numbers that I can get from
those Million numbers that would also
tell you apart from someone else ok so
you're absolutely right you use this for
dimensionality reduction and we usually
write this as a big matrix u times
another big matrix Sigma times a
slightly smaller but also sometimes big
matrix V star and the columns of U are
ordered from most important to least
important in their ability to capture
this data and notice that the columns of
U are the same size as a column of X so
the in the example that we're gonna do
today I'm gonna take a bunch of faces a
bunch of pictures of faces so we're
gonna have face 1 X 1 face 2 X 2 and so
on up to face em X em and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to take these 2
dimensional arrays and I'm just gonna
reshape them so that they're a really
really big tall skinny vector okay
pretty simple to do in MATLAB I just do
the reshape command so easy in MATLAB
reshape and I take all of these let's
say that it's a thousand by a thousand
so I have a million pixels
I just reject that into a million by one
column vector and it just will go from
RORO stacking these numbers okay so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna find that
we can take each of these images and
stack them as a column vector in X we're
going to run the singular value
decomposition and we're gonna get an
ordered set of modes you from most
important to least important and what's
really important about these ordered
sets of you is that you one is a million
pixels and I can reshape this back into
a face so what I get out are my dominant
eerie-looking you'll find that they're
eerie-looking eigenfaces these are the
columns of U so they're they're very
interpretable okay any questions about
where we're going with that so far make
sense okay you can do this for any data
this is not I'm giving you an example of
faces because it's very intuitive but
you can do this for any data that you
collect in a laboratory you can do this
for you know if I have a wind tunnel and
I'm collecting velocity fields I can do
eigenfaces on my velocity fields I can
do eigenfaces to follow the disease
spread in Africa or in you know in the
flu on the east coast or something like
that okay so the examples that we're
going to do are the following we're
going to have I have 20 images of Arnold
Schwarzenegger so I picked superheroes
see if I can make this a little bigger
so we have 20 images of him in all of
his awesome action movies I just
downloaded these off the internet one
night when I was bored and cropped them
and formatted them so that they're all
the same size I think it's 200 by 175
pixels okay and then I also took
Stallone so this is going to be an
action figure
machine-learning we're gonna we're gonna
try to tell the difference between two
classic action heroes with our computer
okay so then I have 20 Stallone pictures
too
okay make sense so we're gonna clear all
close all CLC I'm going to enter in the
size of my image so M is 200 and is 175
I should probably put in comments size
of image and feel free to interrupt at
any point you know ask as many questions
as you want
and I have number of sample images per
person so n is 20 I have 20 sample
images for each of these people okay and
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to create
a big data matrix X where the first half
of it is Arnold and the second half of
it is Stallone and I'm also going to
compute the average face so I'm gonna
just make some space for that right now
so my average face is just 0 size n by n
times n by 1 my average face is going to
be a big column vector of size 200 times
175 and then I'm gonna store everything
in a big matrix a so sometimes I call it
big X sometimes I call it big a doesn't
really matter what I call it so I'm
creating a big empty matrix a and I'm
just gonna keep tacking on column
vectors every time I load a new image ok
so now we're gonna load Arnold so count
equals 0 for J equals 1 to N and as 20
we're going to make a figure I'm gonna
say F F equals faces arnold num2 string
J so what I'm doing is I'm creating a
string that has the file name it's in
folder faces it's called Arnold oh one
dot jpg Oh to jpg oh three jpg so on and
so forth this is just how you
concatenate strings with numbers inside
of them in MATLAB
so FF is my file name U is going to be
an image read of this file name so I'm
going to read image
into you I really shouldn't call this
you I should probably call this X why
don't I just do that that's X okay and
if it's a color image then it's gonna
have three channels it's gonna have a
red a green and a blue channel and so
I'm just gonna do if the size of X if
this if the what am I trying to say if
this thing has three dimensions if size
comma 3 equals 1 then I'm going to do M
double of X else I'm going to say M
equals double of RGB 2 grey of U of X
good things so basically what I'm saying
is if it's already gray so these numbers
and X are gonna be numbers from 0 to 255
images you know any grayscale color can
be represented approximately from 0 to
255 where 0 is either all black or all
whites and 255 is the opposite eye
they're all white or all black but if
this thing does have 3 channels that I'm
going to convert the 3 channels to gray
and then turn it into a double okay and
pause 0.1 R equals reshape my so my
image M is now an array 200 by 175 and I
need to reshape that into a big column
vector so before it was M by n or n by M
now it's M times n by one a big column
vector and finally I'm gonna stack that
big column vector into my matrix a so a
is my growing list of images should I
call this X maybe would that make
everyone happier if I call it the same
thing that I always call it let's do
that and my average is gonna get bigger
I'm gonna keep adding R to my average
count equals count plus 1 and when I
read in my image I'm also going to show
you my image I'm gonna do M show of you
have we done image analysis in class
before if we done loads and shows and
things like that yeah ok good X good
thank you it's a really bad idea to try
to change variables while you're coding
lives okay so hopefully this will
actually run I'm just gonna try it okay
good right of course that doesn't work
because this needs to be percent o to D
it tried to load Arnold one JPEG but my
files are Arnold o 1 o 2 O 3 so this
needs to be padded with to 0 it needs to
have it two digits padded by zeros 0 1 0
2 up to 10 and 11 12 13 and so on ok
Arnold 1 2 3 4 so you can't see this can
you some of them are popping down to the
bottom of my screen which is irritating
just try to make it so you can actually
see these images
okay good so we're loading in all of
these images every time we load it in we
convert it to gray we restock it into a
big tall column vector of size 200 times
175 and we concatenate it in as columns
of this big matrix X okay make sense and
now I'm gonna do the same thing for
Stallone I think my code shouldn't
change at all except now faces should be
faces slash Stallone we're still gonna
print we're still gonna reshape we're
still gonna pause we're still gonna add
to the average and add to the counts and
then after the end of this I'm gonna say
average equals average / count okay good
Stallone all 20 of him okay so what size
should my X matrix be at this point so
if I type size of big X what should this
be now okay so it should be 200 times
175 whatever the height however many
pixels I have and I should have 40 of
those columns I do this it should be
yeah
35,000 by 40 okay that's what we want
okay there's a couple of pre-processing
steps so something that I haven't told
you up until this point is the data
scrubbing to get your matrix X clean
before you run the SVD is probably the
most important part it's even more
important it's as important as the SVD
so there's a couple more things we're
gonna do the first thing we're gonna do
is compute the average face this is
Stallone we're gonna compute the average
face so the average is au int 8 of
reshape my average and comma n okay so
what I'm doing is I'm taking my average
face which was a really tall vector I'm
reshaping it into a picture size thing
200 by 175 and I'm converting it back
into a number between 0 and 255
that I can plot it as an image that's
you in Tate I'm just taking my double
precision number and I'm turning it into
something that looks like an integer
between zero and 255 it just means it's
an unsigned 8-bit integer so there's
eight zeros or ones that you can use to
make a number from zero to 255 okay and
then we're gonna make figure one image
show average TS okay so this is my
average face this is the average of both
this is my average action-hero okay you
can see hair eyes nose mouth but not
really much else right there's not a lot
of other features there besides just it
looks kind of like a person okay
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to take each of the images in my
each column of this matrix and I'm gonna
subtract out the average face because I
want to know what is different between
each of these images and the mean so
this is kind of like principal
components analysis we're mean
subtracting and then we're gonna plot
that okay so Center the sample pictures
at the origin that's another way of
saying I'm gonna subtract the mean face
this is a huge vector space with 35,000
dimensions and we're gonna subtract
everything so that all of my images are
centered around the origin I'm gonna
subtract out the mean of my of my pixels
okay so figure one for J equals 1 to 2
times n I'm gonna say a J you know X J
equals x J minus the average right
subtract the average from every column
and then I'm gonna just plot it so you
can see what it looks like
and I'm putting a pause in there because
this computer is way too fast to see no
something bad happens that should be an
X right okay pretty sure I have messed
something up here but we're just going
to keep looking something looks really
bad here
so what I'm probably gonna do is
actually rerun the script that I know
works after I type all this thing
because I'm sure I mess something up so
we're loading everything in okay all the
Stallone we're gonna compute the average
face in a minute and now what we're
plotting is the face the average all of
my face is minus the average face and
they look really terrible I think for
some reason these aren't coming out very
well maybe I'll just go to my demo that
definitely works just to make sure I'm
not doing something wrong
yeah these look more like it so what do
you notice about these faces compared to
the the faces that I loaded before like
this is my this is an image minus the
mean what do you notice about it well so
it's not great it looks much more black
and white and what else do you notice
well so my average face average that all
the shadows and all the lighting angles
and all the ways that the faces were
turned and so here you see just very
high contrast features associated with
like dominant facial features and
shadows right you see like this is
Stallone's nose shadow right and these
are his eye brows and eyes and hair and
you don't see all of the other my new
show right it's just the high contrast
variance features from the mean okay so
they should be much higher contrast okay
I'm gonna go back to doing everything
with A's because I know how aids work so
now what I'm gonna do is I have this big
matrix that has all of my images and now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna take
the SVD of
a and if I say comma 0 this is the same
as saying comma econ and the idea here
is if I have a matrix that's really
really asymmetric like it's really tall
and skinny or really short and fat then
I want to do the economy SVD because
it'll be a lot faster okay so I'm doing
the economy SVD and we know that the
columns of U are arranged in order of
importance from the most important Augen
face I'm calling it I in face because
we're solving an eigenvalue
decomposition problem to get it and the
second one is the second most important
Tigan face the third most the fourth
most etc and so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take my my modes u my eigenfaces
I'm gonna put them in a matrix feed and
I'm gonna plot the first nine eigenfaces
for you so for I equals one two three
four J equals one two three I'm going to
show you my reshaped eigen face
okay so these are my eigen heroes right
this is my first most dominant most
important eigen face for the data with
with Arnold and Stallone again it looks
kind of like the mean again just an
average face second third for us and so
on and so you can start seeing features
here so some of these have Terminator
glasses right like you can start seeing
pieces of Arnold in these eigenfaces
dominant things that come up over and
over again here I'm not sure if you can
see it at this resolution but this is
pretty clearly Stallone's eye you get
like a Stallone eye popping up an eigen
face 3 and all kinds of other other
stuff happening ok so these are my eigen
faces the most dominant 9 features of my
40 images ok and now the next thing I
can do is kind of cool so I have these
these modes these eigen faces
I'm calling them fee and so what I can
do is I can take the first three columns
of fee and I can multiply it by my
entire my image vector X so for the case
image I can multiply it I can take the
inner product of this vector with these
three first three eigen faces and I get
three numbers alpha 1 alpha 2 and alpha
3 that tell me how much does this
picture have of those three eigen faces
okay gives me coordinates so essentially
what I'm able to do is I'm able to take
every image and project it into an eigen
face space a space span by eigenfaces by
my first three eigen faces and so that's
what I'm gonna do here so I'm for the
first 20 pictures I'm going to compute
Arnold's three numbers for every image
in the Arnold set and then for the next
20 I'm gonna pick all of the images of
Stallone and I'm gonna take his images
and our product with my first three
eigen faces and I'm gonna get three
numbers for all of my 40 pictures
and then I'm gonna plot my Arnold points
as red dots and I'm gonna plot my
Stallone points as blue dots in I ghen
face space okay so what do you think is
gonna happen when I do the Arnold and
Stallone eigen face space maybe they'll
separate let's see okay good so here we
have our eigen face space this is a
space a vector space spanned by eigen
space eigenfaces right so this is eigen
face one two and three and for every
image for every image in my training set
of Arnold and Stallone I can find out
what is the mixture of these three eigen
faces that go into that face and these
are how I plot the coordinates so you
can actually see I'll just make this
rotate a little bit it's not perfect
separation but you actually get pretty
decent clustering right like you could
at least convince yourself kind of that
Arnold is on one side and Stallone's on
the other and there's a few cases where
they mix a little bit okay any questions
about this before we go to the next part
alright this is starting to look a lot
like the ovarian cancer data set right
you have two different types of data
lots and lots of data for each
observation but when you plot them in a
low dimensional feature space you start
to see big differences between these
distributions okay so what does this
mean for you know machine learning and
Facebook and training my computer to
tell action heroes apart so I might be
able to differentiate between two people
so one thing that I could do is I could
tell my computer there's mathematical
ways to formalize this but I can
essentially say it looks like if I drew
a line here I would get maybe 80% of
these images right so I'll just draw a
line in I can face space and any time I
get a new image it's a really easy
procedure to classify I take my new
image I do its inner product with these
three vectors I get three numbers I plot
those three numbers and depending on
which side of this dividing line I'm on
I'll either paint it red and call it
Arnold or I paint it blue and call it
Stallone okay that's completely
automatic my computer can do all of
those steps without me and it gets a
prediction it either will tell me I
think this image is Arnold or I think
this image is Stallone so that's the
next part so the next step is we're
gonna load some unexpected pictures that
were not in my training set so I trained
on 40 images now we're gonna add these
two images okay so someone photoshopped
Harry Potter Stallone and this is the TV
Terminator not Arnold but it's a
terminator okay so we think that this
one should maybe go in the Stallone
cluster maybe and this one should maybe
go in the Arnold cluster because it's a
terminator okay and well again what's
the procedure I take these two images
and how do i how do I get my computer to
do this classification what's the first
step
okay reshape them into tall vectors good
luck
well I already did the SPD of my big
training center so I had my training
sets I have use I have my product right
so I take each of these newly shaped
column vectors and I take their three
dot products with my three first most
important item phases and I just plot
their coordinates and I see where they
fall okay so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna say the Stallone points are
I already did this inner product right
here
so my Stallone picture I enter product
did it and my Arnold picture I also in a
product it it and so yeah V term my
Terminator points in my Stallone points
and I'm gonna plot Stallone as a green
dot and Terminator as a black dot okay
Terminator was a black dot and Stallone
was a green dot and you see that very
nicely they actually fall I would say
pretty safely in the region right so the
Terminator gets classified as a
terminator dot an Arnold dot and the
Stallone picture that was not in my
training set would most likely get
classified as a Stallone type picture
okay so this information is sufficient
to train your computer to tell people
apart and to actually do a decent job of
predicting who someone is if you haven't
seen their picture that new picture
before okay questions yeah within a
certain range of this line
we're fighting it can you have a add in
extra dimension okay so that's a really
good question
you can give a confidence score so if I
had enough images and these are crappy
images that I cropped by hand and did a
bunch of stuff too but if I had a better
data set with more images and more
people than I could probably assign some
kind of a statistical confidence to how
confident am I that this is Arnold
versus Stallone and if I'm you know less
than 75% confident or eighty percent
confident I can tell you that like if
I'm really close to this line here and
you don't know I can tell you that I'm
fifty percent you know I can't tell it's
in two indistinguishable I could also do
something where if my black point was
way out there I can tell you it's
probably neither of them it's probably
not Arnold or Stallone
okay other other examples or questions
let's do a couple more I have other
images okay so we have Arnold and
Stallone what if we try our and old and
Taylor Swift what do you think is gonna
what is your hypothesis here you think
the clusters will be more separate okay
how many of you agree with this
prediction how many of you disagree okay
let's see so all of our Taylor pictures
okay let's look at the mean face this is
my new average face a little more and a
little different we're gonna reshape the
images let's say if I can let's see if I
can make this position a little bit
better
okay so I'm gonna subtract the mean from
every face and plopping for you all of
you Arnold
all the Taylor these look like images
you could silkscreen based on their
really high contrast blocky high
variance images and we're gonna compute
the SVD and plot the first nine
eigenfaces okay now the first one is
again a mean face but the proportions
are a little bit different because you
have a different person in there again
lots of Terminator glasses in fact all
of the higher modes to me at least look
a lot like Arnold this one especially
but those are my eigen faces and you can
decide in the first three eigenfaces do
some of them look more like Arnold or
more like Taylor Swift probably okay and
now what we're going to do is I'm gonna
keep calling her Stallone but it's
really just Taylor and we're just gonna
plot all of these images
yikes okay now I would say personally
that this looks worse to me okay so why
might that be why might these actually
be separating less well than Stallone
and Arnold it's it's as simple as that
I think it's as simple as complexion and
hair color they just have more light
pixels than dark pixels right and so
this mixture is like very very
susceptible to things like I'm taking
the inner products of these numbers
right so if I have more small numbers on
the cheeks those are going to correlate
have right so things like there's
something you can do to fix this which
would be to take every column and take
the unit variance divided by its
variance that would be a way of bringing
them all to the same gray level okay and
that's actually a really important
and PCA is to to bring out divided by
the variance of each of these images so
that you renormalize all of the colors
make sense okay and then just to be
complete let's try Stallone and Taylor
where's your hypothesis here more
separation hopefully
okay I got to do all the steps my
average face now is like that looks a
lot like Taylor Swift if you can see it
on my computer
okay I'm gonna subtract out the mean
face okay good
take the eigenfaces first nine
eigenfaces now these always look a
little creepier to me yeah so these are
my first nine eigenfaces some of them
are just hair like apparently that's an
eigen faces just err actually maybe not
surprisingly because they have different
hair colors so maybe their eyebrows and
stuff for difference and now I'm going
to project Stallone and Taylor into my
eigen face space and lo and behold I get
very nice separation not perfect but you
I mean that's really really good
separation right they're not mixed at
all hardly so very good clean separation
with Stallone and Taylor probably a lot
of it are things like I mean the fact
that they're like one's a guy and one's
a girl definitely will help but the fact
that they have different complexion and
different hair color helps even more I
think okay okay so so maybe we should
just take a step back and ask some
general questions about this like well
are there any questions about the math
or what we're doing or the procedure
you can do this yourself you can take
your image and plot it in these
coordinates
there's also websites where you can see
which movie star you look the most like
yeah beyond this because Facebook for
example might get me mixed up with my
brother but it's not gonna get me mixed
up with my girlfriend mmm but this thing
looks like it would yeah okay so that's
a really good so that's that's kind of
the next line of question so how would
we make this better
what are all the things we could do to
make this better yeah so use more yeah
I'm just showing you I can phases one
through three so I can pop but I could
use I can phases one through ten right
and maybe the ninth IgAN face is exactly
what's different between Taylor and
Stallone and they separate big time okay
so I could use more features plus sorry
a larger training set would absolutely
help high-resolution images all of that
yes fancier yeah so I was saying well
let's just draw some crummy line in here
but maybe I maybe there's actually some
surface that really does separate these
and maybe if I had a thousand picture to
do that I don't see that much more
clearly so better classification
techniques and there's hundreds okay
because there's a lot of money in a good
classification other things you could do
to make it better the most important
ones have yet to be said
shape the shape the shape of what okay
so this is the this is the one of the
most important points remember that the
image that I the images that I put up I
mean I was I was watching one of these
movies on Wikipedia or Google Images
pulling them and manually cropping and
reshaping them so the cropping and
reshaping of these images was pretty
poor right I did it by hand I wasn't
paying that much attention but the the
trick that makes image recognition by
far more accurate like it can boost you
from maybe 75 or 80 percent into the 90s
is the following so let's say that I
have a face and it's turned at an angle
and all of our faces have different
proportions some are taller some are
wider my eyes aren't the same spacing is
all of yours and my like we all have
different geometry that's part of what
makes our faces recognizable but in
addition to that different geometry we
also have different noses eyes and
mouths if you just zoomed in okay so the
step that makes the biggest difference
and this was largely done here at u-dub
so a lot of this research is done here
in computer science is to find the
features so there are things that will
track corners of eyes corners of nose
corners of mouth and kind of giving you
the quick and dirty outline of this and
then what you do is you can map those to
a standard grid so I can take every
single face in this room even though we
all have different sizes shapes
geometries even though we're all at
different angles and at different
lighting and I can stretch out this face
so that it's kind of mapped to a very
regular area where if I want to compare
your two noses I know exactly where to
look it's not like they're in different
places on the image
they've been mapped to this exact same
box of pixels okay so the data scrubbing
step before I even stack my vectors as
columns and do the SVD getting my data
into the cleanest most well aligned way
possible is by far the most
Gordon step in any classification any
classification and the way I think about
this is this allows you to do an
apples-to-apples comparison between
people and that's what you always want
to be thinking about in your data does
my data the way that I'm stacking it
allow me to do apples to apples
comparison does this row mean the same
thing across all of these images and it
doesn't here but it does here make sense
okay good the next so this gets you to
like Facebook performance three years
ago but recently Facebook has actually
made a huge leap in facial recognition
and they're in some limited tests
actually performing as well as humans
which is pretty remarkable so humans can
do something like 97 to 98% accurate on
a test called same different and so you
essentially take a big library of images
and I'll present you with two images and
you have to tell me do those belong to
the same person or a different person
and humans can get this about ninety
seven point five percent of the time and
until recently Facebook was at you know
a lot less than that maybe in the night
like low 90s and recently they jumped to
ninety seven ninety seven point five
percent which is human accuracy at
telling faces apart any guesses how you
would take that next final leap in
facial recognition so in the real
facebook deal you might be able to add
color these might be longer features
that have the color channels normalized
somehow but that's a good idea
one other yeah so think along those
lines what other dimensions of the data
might I be missing so age you could
build a statistical model based on that
what else
what else is different between all of
our faces that's not necessarily
counselor here sorry all right so the
ethnicity will largely be captured by
the normalization and the remapping like
a lot of that will be captured by just
mapping us to the same uniform like
standard that mean easel look super
creepy but you can just do that okay
what else is missing in this this image
this 2d array of numbers that we're
going to snap into a combo I'm you could
pretty much get the gender like at a low
level you think you can get the gender
from this
is it a morphological feature is it a
particular feature of our face what do
you mean by morphological like sort of a
shape factor yes so it is a
morphological feature in fact let's just
call it that so like the only other
difference it's not being accounted for
here or one of the major differences
that's not being accounted is we're
getting 2d shape but we're not getting
3d shape like maybe my ears are just
farther back and so if it looks they
look pretty big but like maybe you know
all of us have different features maybe
my nose just casts a bigger shadow or a
smaller shadow or you know we have depth
to our face we're not 2d images walking
around in flatland and so the big
quantum leap that Facebook made and this
is what we all do is like when I look at
a face I don't just see a 2d mapped
image I see a 3d skull representation
right like I know what your skulls look
like it sounds super creepy but so they
can actually take these images and now
get a statistically best-fit skull that
would match I don't know if they use
things like age and gender and race they
might they might not they might not need
to but they definitely use the color
values and the intensities to map this
to a skeleton and then from that that
additional piece of information your
classification just goes through the
roof and that's really what what people
are doing okay so it's kind of
bio-inspired and that's how you bridge
the gap okay so you're always trying to
find what dimensions are not being
modeled in your data how to add them and
renormalization technique so that you're
really doing Apple to Apple comparisons
okay so that Taylor and Arnold don't
just look the same because they're both
blondes okay yeah
who pictures do they only have access to
pictures that are 2d okay so this is a
good point but they do have laboratories
and billions of dollars okay so they
actually build I'll show you what they
do so you can do this with lots of other
things you can do this with pets dogs
and cats eigen pets okay these are my
first four eigen pets what they've done
this is the Yale database you can
download this I work on this database a
lot so what they do is they take a bunch
of people and they put them inside of
this big dome with lights and cameras
okay and so within two seconds so you're
sitting in this chair and within two
seconds they flash all of the lights at
64 different illuminations and they take
64 pictures of you and they do that when
you're angry mad sad happy bow so
they'll have you know thousands of
images for 60 or 70 people and so you
can take this this Yale faces data base
and they've also already been cropped
and aligned according to the techniques
I'm telling you about and so these are
your eigen faces when you actually do
this smart thing and get different
illuminations and you properly align and
these look much more like faces right
these don't like my Arnold and Stallone
faces look kind of crummy because they
were all misaligned but these look way
way way way better and so based on this
information and some of this depth
information you can actually start
finding statistical best fits to
skeletons so to just structures to 3d
structures now I think it's really
important to note that you don't this
these don't have to be images these can
be any measurements these can be
measurements of polio in Nigeria right
all of these districts could be stacked
as a big vector and the measurements
that every day or every week or every
month could be my column vectors and you
can essentially do this exact same you
can find eigen disease patterns right
you can find patterns where your disease
are most likely to be correlated you can
also put buoys in the ocean and every
measurement can be the buoy measurements
at a given point in time and you can
find I
patterns in the ocean or weather
stations it turns out that insects have
strain sensors all over their wings
every flying insect has on the order of
50 to 100 strain sensors and so you can
start finding patterns that these strain
sensors would show in unison or in
concert during normal healthy flight if
you wanted to be a little bit sadistic
you could clip some of these wings and
you would see how the patterns change in
flight because the aerodynamics and the
coupled structure are also going to be
different and maybe it's important for
these insects to have these patterns as
they're growing and developing so that
they can learn to fly by sensing these
low dimensional patterns of the wind
okay my wife made eigen Steve's from all
of the images she has of me so these are
eigen these are my eigen faces they're
not skeletally reconstructed yet but you
can really do this for absolutely any
data the trick is just to make sure that
you can stack it in a way that you're
doing apples to apples comparisons okay
okay other questions about eigenfaces or
the SVD on data
okay that's all I have it has been a
pleasure teaching all of you I hope to
see you all for the next year's and have
a great spring break thank you